il y a un chantier à poursuivre à
développer qui est celui de
l'optimisation des ouvrages hydrauliques
existants un inventaire par
photosatellite a été fait nous avons sur
le territoire national environ 350 000
réserves de plus de 0,1 nectar de
superficie
c'est un patrimoine qui est colossal et
le
l'inspection générale du développement
durable est en train de travailler sur
la méthodologie pour pouvoir
utiliser
cette masse d'information dans les
territoires parce que une fois qu'on a
la photographie il faut savoir qui est
propriétaire de l'ouvrage dans quel état
et l'ouvrage est-ce qu'il y a à
proximité ou non des exploitations qui
peuvent être intéressés par l'irrigation
comment on gère la relation entre le
propriétaire de l'ouvrage et
des exploitations et bien entendu tout
l'aspect des conséquences
environnementales